[Music]
[Applause]
occasionally we are blessed with the
show which upsets the natural order of
things and oftentimes can change the way
we view entire genres or a medium the
original Mobile Suit Gundam
revolutionized the way we saw mecca's
grounding it in a commentary of war and
politics akira opened up the door to
international acclaim pushing the limits
of what animation can do that stands to
this day but today I would like to bring
attention to a currently airing show
which I feel it's a classic in the
making that would change the landscape
and will be talked about for years to
come the masterpiece that is arrow manga
sensei masterfully disguised as the
typical fanservice harem show we've seen
a million times every season one can
easily a signal this is just another
otaku bait anime appealing to the lowest
common denominator but the more I
watched the more I came to the
realization that error manga sensei is a
true masterpiece of our time now
understandably you may be skeptical with
words like masterpiece being thrown
around a lot these days but I assure you
those of us who understand can attest to
everything that this show has been able
to achieve sensei is the latest addition
to the glorious Emoto genre which has
seen a huge surge within anime in recent
years as long with genres like t you say
kaiju on refer slice-of-life genre and
the dear God just please kill it with
fire genre for those who underwear Emoto
is the Japanese name given to the
littles
sister and the genre normally involves a
focus on her and her onii-chan which
translated to english is basically what
she calls her [__] buddy coming from the
same lights novel author that wrote the
revolutionary my little sister can't be
this cute a show which everyone thought
was going to be the good old incest
bait-and-switch only to realize that the
show was doing exactly what it said on
the [__] tin his latest work aims to
push the boundary even further on his
eternal mission to alienate every
sibling pair on earth and possibly the
entire cosmos this time it focuses on a
young light novel author who discovers
his shot and little sister was the
famous erotic illustrator era manga
sensei who has been drawing the
illustrations for him this entire time
and thus we follow our daily adventures
as our lead meets a bunch of other on
the rage girls who vie for his attention
I guess is not related by blood little
sister now you may be asking yourself
how can such a series be considered a
masterpiece I mean it just sounds like
another super trashy show this is a
common misconception as era manga sensei
isn't just a trashy show highschool DxD
is a trashy show high school for the
Dead is a trashy show Hamato Amaru chard
is a trashy show our manga sensei it's
something else it is an enigma that
transcends the limits of trash itself to
become something beyond a perfect car
crash of garbage that takes the lowest
common denominator and divides that by
zero this isn't just trash it's a
full-on [__] landfill and in doing so
has become the ultimate work of art not
all heroes wear capes and not all art
belongs in a gallery but if a urinal can
be tastefully presented as an art piece
then we must ask why can't we do the
same with a lolly saying I love dick but
of course not all art can be appreciated
by everyone which is why to understand
the full extent of this masterpiece one
needs to fully accept who they really
are
in buddhism it is said that the root of
all suffering is attachment and error
manga sensei has a similar mind
about it for you see it is this
attachment you must first sever yourself
from before you will be ready
appreciation can only be achieved once
you let go of everything self-esteem
shame human decency dignity and any
chance of your parents looking at you
with pride
you must dedicate years of your life
enveloped in the world of anime and I'm
not talking about good well-written
shows fanservice glorious jiggling tits
uncomfortable fetishes adorable anime
girls becoming one with the idea of
panty shots throw yourself off the deep
end with no safety net to catch you has
only once you are fully dedicated to
this lifestyle will you reach true
enlightenment and come to the
realization of the one undeniable truth
of this world anime is trash and so am I
you see to fully comprehend trash you
must first become it and once you have
reached this higher plane of degeneracy
where you begin to realize the miracle
that has befallen us here because this
is beyond what everyone thinks it is
it's not really an incest show because
they aren't related by blood and that
makes it totally acceptable and you see
it's not this weird sexual ization of
twelve-year-old lollies because they're
just anime characters that don't even
exist
officer somehow the show manages to keep
topping itself every week which is a
testament to how revolutionary it is
every episode you go in thinking there's
no way this show can go any lower and
then against all odds it does see what
other shows may say panty shot
fanservice era manga has the guts to say
mo a lolly incest siscon bondage panty
shot fanservice with a dash of o
chinjung if there was a single flaw in
this show it would be probably with the
title arrow manga sensei is short
relevant and to the point but with only
two words I think there is vast room for
improvement as this is nowhere near the
recommended word count for a standard
light novel title some more suitable
examples could have been my little
sister can't be this cute but this time
she draws lewd art and his 12 surely
there's no possible way we can
let's go trash ear next week right or my
personal favorite buckets I was already
going to hell this is not mentioning one
of the greatest opening and ending
sequences to ever grace the world of
anime and no it's not because of this
expertly drawn calf muscle but of course
the sagar ii dance previous anime dances
may have spread through this community
through a catchy well animated
choreographed dance but our manga sensei
asks why do you need to put all that
effort in when you can just wave your
arms around like some kawaii [__] oh you
know it's whatever maybe I'm overstating
it I mean it's just a cute girl waving
her arms around at the end of the day
right it's not like I could watch this
on repeat for hours or something you
know it's not it's not a dick ting I
don't I don't have a problem yet somehow
against all odds the show I somehow
managed to dodge a best girl war as we
all have a mutual understanding of
whoever we choose as best girl we are
all losers anyway I mean we all know
that Segura is going to win so what's
the point of resisting that when we
already have someone top-tier ok maybe
you're someone who thinks someone like
Amelia is a good waifu and if you do
that's completely fine I have the
highest respect for garbagemen and the
work that they do but you have to ask
yourself is she a socially awkward Emoto
lolly who draws lewd pictures steals
panties and permanently sounds like
she's doing ASMR if the answer is no
then that might be a sign for some
self-reflection you'd think it ends here
but it goes even deeper as episode a
blows everything out of the water see
with a scene in this episode we get a
shot of Curran EKKO confirming that the
show indeed takes place in the same
universe as Oreimo but we can also
confirm that both Moroka and sword art
online exists in some form also through
references the implications of which are
massive as this could indicate the
beginning of a franchise to rival Marvel
itself
Sagar II Keira no Miyuki
and sugu could join together to create
the world's first
Emoto Cinematic Universe we're getting
the ICU baby
it's the ultimate appreciation of things
only the Japanese can do see the
Japanese are absolute experts are
creating these little inventions you
didn't know you needed until you saw
them just go into any die so and you'll
see what I mean
I didn't know a pretty stick of butter
would be something I wanted until I saw
that a tie that doubles up as an
umbrella would be hello useful for
living in the UK and until I saw
Eromanga sensei I had no idea what I
needed in life was an adorably mototool
I should call me Barker so by now you're
hopefully more understanding of the
masterpiece that is Eromanga sensei
anyone pictures have absolutely outdone
themselves and I'm not sure what they
could possibly do to get this work
closer to perfection a minute that they
just added
tournament
[Music]
in short Eromanga sensei is a
masterpiece a show we only get once a
generation which is why I can
wholeheartedly say that we are
witnessing this cultural revolution in
action it's a show that reaches new
heights of degeneracy trash that
transcends the idea of trash and
something that can only be admired by
those few brave warriors who have given
up on everything in years past we will
look at this time as the redefining era
we'll say the world was never the same
after era manga sensei era manga sensei
contributed to world peace era manga
sensei solved world hunger era manga
sensei isn't just cancer era manga
sensei gave me cancer and then cured it
and then gave me aids instead
I love
[Music]